hi everyone today I'm here at ETH Zurich
in Switzerland and I'm here with Jess
she runs a channel called stamina and
I'll put some links down to her stuff in
the description but I thought we'd have
a bit of a conversation today about what
it's like studying at somewhere like ETH
European University and because you're a
student from abroad you're from Canada
so maybe comparing what it's like to
study here versus back home what the
exams maybe look like yeah I mean
definitely for I think it was a bit of a
shock when I first came here because
well first of all it was the difference
between undergraduate and master's exams
but additionally I think there's a quite
a bit of a difference between Canadian
exams and European exams in Canada I've
never had an oral exam they were all
sort of like those written exams that
you've shown before on your channel for
example the MIT exam that you've shown
on your channel they're all pretty
similar you know 3 / 6 problem-solving 3
hours so you I didn't say that you're a
mechanical engineering yeah so my
master's was in mechanical engineering
with a concentration in aerospace so
yeah all of my classes were yeah just
typical mechanical engineering with
additional aerospace classes and I would
say only a few of my exams have been
those type of written exams but most of
them have been oral exams which are sort
of foreign to me so I'd like did my
undergrad in Australia New Zealand and
yeah I've written exams are pretty much
all I've ever done I've done one oral
exam for electronics but okay I've never
had to actually really explain physics
what is an oral exam like how how are
you tested on just working as I can
interview yeah so basically it's 30
minutes and the prof and there's usually
two or three profs there so one person
is scribing down what you're writing and
then the profit is kind of grilling you
and what happens is that yeah so you
come in by yourself and
when they're telling you to study for
the exam they're always telling you to
like we're not there to see what you
don't know we're there to see how much
you do know and that's a lie they're
definitely there to find out what part
of the course you don't know so for
example in any course you have what 10
different chapters of things that you
need to know and then generally on your
engineering exams on your written exams
you have 6 questions that will sort of
cover everything in that exam and what I
found with oral exams is that the prof
kind of has those six questions on their
paper but they'll ask you three of them
and then if you're good at answering
those first three then they'll start
asking you the other three so for
example I was taking my combustion class
exam they asked me to draw a diagram of
flame temperature versus equivalence
ratio doesn't matter if you don't know
what that is I'm just giving an example
so like a pen and paper I know so
sometimes they make you go up to the
board and sometimes they give you the
paper and then like it's kind of more
casual because you can sit down but
sometimes you're standing in front of
them and presenting and it's kind of
awkward so for example when I drew my
diagram I drew it for one specific case
and then they're like they ask you
everything about the diagram you drew if
you didn't draw it properly so they're
like Oh
normally would it be so pointed and
you're like no actually this is in the
perfect case and they're like okay well
when what would be a non perfect case
and then you have to kind of draw it in
every way and then they're like oh well
what happens if you increase the
temperature what happens if you change
the the species like how would the
diagram shift this is just one example
so basically they're trying to quiz your
most fundamental knowledge of a specific
question so even if you answer it
perfectly on a written exam it's not the
same because if you answer it perfectly
in an oral exam they'll be like okay but
and then they'll just keep asking you
additional things I kind of finally you
know it breaks exactly so they will kind
of just keep asking you questions until
you start to stutter
which is fine because sometimes so the
grades the way it works is that a four
is a fail and a six is a perfect so
anywhere in between your grade can lie
as long so if you answer that first
question you're out of four and then the
more they keep asking you and the more
knowledge that they keep trying to get
from you and like okay but okay but okay
by your grade will kind of increase the
more of those questions that you can
answer it sounds actually similar to the
one oral exam I've had where it was like
yeah it was like nerve wracking because
you know that the more questions they
ask you're eventually going to get to a
point where you're just floundering and
that's sort of embarrassing but on a
written exam you can just put your
answer and just like yeah you don't have
to justify it that much but um I
remember like I was being asked
questions and I was like drawing house
if it would work and he was like asking
me like what would change if we like
changed this component to a capacitor
and I'd be like yeah I think maybe you
shouldn't be so scared of reaching that
point where it breaks down because to
have gotten to that point anyway you've
probably done all right yeah that's
exactly it so they sort of have these
base questions where they'll be like do
they know the most basic knowledge about
this course and then once you've
answered those questions you kind of get
a four which is a pass and then after
that they they ask you to build off of
that knowledge and just kind of push you
as far as they possibly can to see if
you can reach a six so do you have any
stories of like actual oral exams that
really you remember yeah I mean I was
going into my turbulence modeling exam
once and I was absolutely terrified for
this exam because there was so much
material and I was I was honestly like
he could ask anything and my fundamental
knowledge can break down yeah so I was
terrified of this exam I ended up
passing I actually did quite well
exam but before I went in the person
before me
came out of the exam and I'm sitting
there like looking over my notes like
really nervous like almost about to
throw up and this guy comes out of the
exam very calmly closes the door starts
walking away and just like go like
screams the F word and it echoed through
the entire hall and I was like and went
inside this was definitely the most
stressful exam I've ever written in my
life they gave me 15 minutes so the exam
is 30 minutes they gave me 15 minutes to
go through and kind of it was it was a
written exam kind of they had written
questions and there was I think six
pages and about five questions on each
page and they gave me 15 minutes to you
don't have to write the answers down you
just kind of have to write like draw a
diagram or like write some key words and
then in the last 15 minutes you go and
you present your explanations and they
would be like why did you write down
this word and I would be like that's
because and then I would relate that to
the answer so some of my answers were
actually blank and in that last 50 like
if I didn't have time to write it I'd be
like I know the answer to that question
it's actually bla bla bla bla bla I
could see how the other guy did terrible
no it was it was honestly the most and
after this exam it was my last exam of
my masters and I was like I definitely
feel like I deserved this degree what
did you do when you lift that exam
there's a reaction to the next person
waiting and no there was no one waiting
after me but it was more of like
okay I'm gonna go get myself some ice
cream well at least you like sort of
left knowing maybe someone else found it
hard to I think it's like really bad if
you even exam you know I talking to your
friends and they like aced it yeah I
know that that's the worst I mean I'm
I'm happy that guy didn't come up to me
afterwards I mean I would have
definitely been like yeah that was hard
but I don't think yeah our exams are
something that are quite common here at
ETA yeah especially in the masters I'm
not quite sure about the bachelors
mm-hmm but what else like so you have
those alongside normal written exams
yeah how would you say like the written
exams here compared to those back home
in Canada like I think in Canada for me
it was quite different and difficult
because at least in Canada I was I was
used to it so I could have sort of every
exam I could sort of expect that there
would be six questions and I would have
30 minutes to answer each problem and
depending on how much time we dedicated
in the class I knew that there's
probably going to be an exact question
on I don't know steam tables in my
thermal class or there's probably gonna
be a question on whatever you could sort
of guess and I think the hardest part of
just starting the master's here was that
I couldn't guess anymore what was going
to be on the exam and also they weren't
those typical six question exams it was
kind of like I opened the exam and there
were 15 questions and then I was like
okay well now now I don't know how much
time did you get dedicated and I don't
know how much they want like they
definitely don't want 30 minutes of
answer anymore but then yeah I don't
know it's really difficult to explain it
sounds like most of the difficulty came
and the fact that it was just not what
you were used to yeah yes
I guess that's gonna be difficult all
the time if you're like you're used to
how it works in one system if you're
studying abroad you just need to get
used to how it works and then you
Society they're not necessarily harder
or easier it's just different at the
exams in English yeah yeah for the
masters they are and to your point that
you were saying that it's hard to get
used to it I think it's easier to get
used to the oral exams here because
you'd do a lot more of them than the
written exams and the written exams are
kind of yeah they're really different
for whatever whatever class you take all
right so we've spoken a little bit about
you know how maybe exams in Europe are a
little bit different so if someone's
coming from say somewhere like Canada
North America just outside of Europe how
would they sort of prepare for exams
here how would you recommend someone
studies for a European exam hmm
well so for example I think in in at
least in Canada in North America when we
get like I was saying earlier about you
can sort of guess what kind of things
what kind what the what the professor
wants know from you so for example in
thermodynamics too they would want to
know if you can solve if you can if you
know how to use steam tables if you know
how to solve some sort of a problem
using steam tables and then if you've
done enough problems you can sort of
expect what kind what I used to it's
like if I've done enough of the past
papers or past like homework questions I
I like it when I feel confident that the
questions in the exam will just be like
a compilation of those yes like if
you've done the practice you can do the
exam yeah and then sometimes they would
ask like kind of like a bonus question
not a bonus but they would put like Oh
what would happen to this table if it
was with this other type of material and
then you're like and then it kind of
tests your fundamental knowledge and if
you don't get it the prof sometimes
doesn't expect you because they don't
really expect engineers to maybe it's
sort of sorts out the top few percent
yeah exactly
whereas here it's absolutely fundamental
to know your fundamentals like I would
suggest that if you were studying for
one of these exams you really like maybe
if you
through a question you have to be like
okay but why and then you try to answer
okay but why and then you just keep
trying to answer it until you break down
- yeah I have no idea so it's like
actually the bigger picture of the idea
it's really down to like I don't you
you're physicists did you do a lot of
entropy stuff like I I know that in my
bachelor's we kind of knew of entropy
but we we sort of just knew how to use
the equations but we didn't really
understand it and the professors always
made this joke that yeah if you don't
understand thermodynamics once you know
that you don't know thermodynamics
whereas here I would say that it's more
of AI think entropy is a good example
because it's sort of this this thing
where like you can use without really
knowing what it is but here they would
expect you to really understand the
fundamentals which if you know anything
about entropy you know it's a really
difficult concept to grasp and it goes
back to like quantum quantum physics
basically and I feel a little bit
conflicted about that because like in
one way if I'm thinking about education
as a whole in my ideal view of education
it's like yeah we should know the
fundamentals we should test the
fundamentals and we should have people
graduating from courses with deep
understanding from these concepts that
they're claiming to know about rather
than just being able to use a couple of
equations yeah on the other side I know
how stressful it is being a student and
like sometimes you just want an exam and
you just have to plug in a few entropy
formulas and like that you just want to
know that you can just show you you can
pass seems really stressful thing and so
like if I was a student I'd be praying
for that like yeah predictable exam but
as like someone who wants a deep
understanding and once I live he would
have deep understanding I like I wanted
to be you know more of this behavior
stuff so I feel like conflicted like um
I feel like I wish I had an easy exam
but everyone's good
yeah well I mean I think it also goes
down to this whole idea that I was
talking about earlier about the four is
the past and the six is the wow you're
really good or whatever because I would
say that most people at ETH pass like
most people have this basic
understanding where they answer the
questions and the professor they're like
okay they they get most of the material
they understand like kind of like what
we do in North America but then if they
try to push for your more fundamental
knowledge that's where you really can
stand out against the rest of the
students and that's where you can be
like no I have fundamental knowledge and
I can and that's where you can sort of
be in the more five six so it's yeah
yeah and so but in general I think
people always joke and switzer and
that's like if you passed ETH like
people will hire you because for this
reason so don't stress too much about
needing a six or whatever yeah I I think
I would I used to strive for like the
perfect grade it was like the A+ you
know for no reason other than I felt
like I wanted to be a perfectionist and
I felt like it was really satisfying to
have a possible in hindsight that a-plus
like it has kind of meant nothing to me
once I got into like a ph.d program I
don't care about his grades anymore and
they caused me so much stresses yes aya
T so yeah yeah and I mean it like you
were saying it's nice to have those it's
nice to want to strive for a six but
don't beat yourself up if you don't get
it I mean I don't think I have a six in
any of my classes I have 15.75 which is
the best grade I have and other ones are
like five point five or five point two
five or five and there have definitely
been times where I felt like I
communicated really perfectly and I
deserved a six and I didn't get one and
you know you can't beat yourself up for
it just do your best and don't worry
about the rest yeah I think we're gonna
film a video
you know you guys can go and check that
out if you're interested in learning
more and thanks for watching
thanks for watching
you